we have still more news to bring you
from that chaotic developing nation
formerly known as the Commonwealth of
Virginia as of tonight Virginia's three
highest ranking public officials all of
them Democrats are embroiled in
potentially career-ending scandals and
it seemed to come out of nowhere just
last week
first you'll remember Democratic
governor Ralph Northam casually endorsed
infanticide while defending a democratic
bill to legalize abortion right up to
the minute of birth then just hours
after he said that a little over a day I
think northern was found to have a
picture of men wearing a Ku Klux Klan
uniform and blackface on his med school
yearbook page loops almost immediately
pretty much the entire Democratic Party
leadership called on Ralph Northam to
resign his office and among the most
vocal was the Attorney General of
Virginia mark herring herring was
appalled appalled that northern would do
this he just couldn't believe that
someone could be that racist and then
today herring admitted that he too has
appeared in blackface which apparently
is the equivalent of business casual for
Democrats in Virginia well herring
resign over this revelation will party
leaders ask him to resign we're still
waiting to find out but in the meantime
were mesmerised as well by the saga of
Virginia lieutenant governor just in
Fairfax just days ago Fairfax thought he
was going to replace Ralph Northam as
governor then it turned out that he too
may be forced to resign from office
because a professor in California called
Vanessa Tyson says that Fairfax
violently sexually assaulted her at the
2004 Democratic National Convention in
Boston where both of them were
volunteering because both are fervent
Democrats at the time Fairfax was a
quote body man for disgraced Senator
John Edwards because the details here
are just too perfect to make up Tyson
came forward a couple of days ago and
when she did according to two sources
who were in the room
Fairfax his first response to the story
from Vanessa Tyson was quote eff that
[ __ ] it's not really the classic
feminist reaction to an allegation of
sexual assault now lieutenant governor
rather Tyson Vanessa Tyson has released
a highly detailed account of what she
says happened to her and how has it
affected her life ever since it's all
online in
makes for harrowing reading if you care
to read it for Democrats so the response
to all of this ought to be really
obvious because they just went through
something amazingly similar a few months
ago another professor from California
accused another public figure of far
less serious crimes with far fewer
corroborating details Democrats know
they have to believe all women they've
told us that countless times but this
time they don't believe all women they
don't care about Vanessa Tyson F her in
the words the lieutenant governor she's
in the way watch presidential candidate
Cory Booker and a self-described a very
good person dismissed Tyson completely
today as unimportant watch this I think
we should be focusing on what's right
now happening with the governor I know
you guys are gonna try to focus on a lot
of things right now but right now my
focus is on again calling for the
governor to step down yeah Booker's got
better things to focus on than some girl
in California was alleging sexual
assault against one of his party mates
the Cory Booker of just a few months ago
would be disgusted by the Cory Booker
you just saw back then sexual politics
seemed more important than race politics
and now it's the other way around it's
the never ending car crash of
intersectionality here's a reminder of
the way it once was how we deal with
survivors who come forward right now is
unacceptable and the way we deal with
this
unfortunately allows for the continued
darkness of this culture to exist and
your brilliance shining light under this
speaking your truth is nothing short of
heroic
well it's short of heroic then it was a
light in the darkness of our culture
that Cory Booker because once again he's
an incredibly good person way better
than you and he went to Yale was gonna
shine to make this a better society now
who cares about this woman will she shut
up already what to make of this sudden
change in attitude